the thing that i i also want to mention
is that
god damn shin noel knows how to draw a
good sex scene
my [ __ ] god that's that's the thing
that's missing because like
okay here's the thing i think [ __ ]
chapter one awoke something in me
you're like you you you remember talking
about like
that new thing yeah where you're just
like wait
what is the new thing the new fetish the
new fetish is just like
this girl who like i've never read a
dozen where like
this sex scene is like this intense i'm
just like like the drugs and [ __ ] yeah
when when karaoke yeah were they
introduced to drugs and it just like
enhanced our experience to a point where
it was just like
not nothing that you can ever experience
on this earth i don't know why i didn't
enjoy that scene that much i'm not
really sure why
no that scene single-handedly awoke that
for me as well
i'm just i'm like i'm just like for me
reading that scene was just like [ __ ]
heavy breathing cats
i'm just like oh god [ __ ] your pc
monitor
jesus christ for a second i like
understood me lynn for like a second
saying something right like i i didn't i
didn't know i could feel this way
and then and then like chapter three
here and i'm just like i think like
my [ __ ] penis shriveled up and it
just inverted back into my body
right that's just like it was just just
like such a whiplash of emotions that
i'm just like
i it went from like oh that's hard to
just like what the [ __ ] am i reading
have you seen that [ __ ] like there's
a thing in the uk where they would go
and that's a tv show they go and visit
tribes and there's just one clip that's
one of my favorite clips
the guy's like there's a ceremony where
they invert their penises and they
invert this dude's penis he immediately
faints
i just imagine i imagine that's what
happened
that's what happened to god he just it's
penis
[Music]
at his pc monitors and he's like what
happened i was reading metamorphosis
there's some his empower i mean
honestly because i feel like the
difference between me and you was just
like at a point i was into it but then i
was just like okay
i i am not into it anymore but i was
like i was like that's why it was so
strong for you because it was like
you were into it at one point and then
it's like it slaps you on the back of
the head it's like
stop it's the way flash of emotion stop
it like like
like my god like like even even during
like some of the later chapters i'm just
like no
no no don't say it no because like his
art is
[ __ ] amazing right it's it's i don't
know how he draws his sex scenes
to be this intense where i'm just like
i'm feeling emotions that i've never
felt before in my life
i was reading this praying i want to go
back to the succubus one
i really what do you all think about the
final chapter
[ __ ] up five percent i think i think
but i think i think because i think
i almost think now hearing your guys
talk like thoughts on it is that this
manga works
amazingly ordojian works amazingly if
you get invested
really heavily in the first part in the
first sex scene yeah because then it
like
like i said it hits you in the back of
the head it's like no yeah don't be
horny
yeah it's bad but horny bad i mean it it
like gave me such a mess of emotions
right because i'm just like i know i
shouldn't be horny right now
this is [ __ ] depressing as [ __ ] this
is [ __ ] up i don't like the guy at all
i think that's why like i couldn't no i
didn't i didn't like the guy at
all i was supposed to like the guy yeah
but that's
to me it's like you know i i the the
whole hotness of the sex
is the duo like okay
someone who is that depressed shouldn't
be making those kinds of facial
expressions
the you can [ __ ] frame some of the
facial expression
what do you mean by that like honestly
okay
okay let's jump right in let's talk
let's talk about the artist
let's talk about the art of the aha gal
right i'm not fond of it you know i've
been oversaturized to it yeah you've
been oversaturated we all have we all
have right
but like his like owl faces are some of
the most
unique [ __ ] faces i've ever seen in
all of hentai it's assangi and shindo
well
i'm not i'm a man of the church though
that's not enough to make me like me
quiver you know i don't i don't see that
i
i'm my wills are not compromised by such
such ill ill foreign connor
that this art piece was so good that it
made me question
it made me question it for a second and
then i was just like no i'm back to it
this is awful
this is the prank [ __ ] name of the
clip for this [ __ ] thing god thought
[ __ ] metamorphosis was the [ __ ]
mona lisa of dogen or some [ __ ] i i
personally think it's the mona lisa
like like okay okay the the reason the
reason why like
i was so engrossed in it is because it
was such like
you love incest and there's interest in
it at some point god
so clearly that's why you like it it was
such a [ __ ] mess of emotions and it
was like an emotional
up and down like it was just down from
the start i knew the moment she was like
i can't make good friends i'm like oh no
that's the only other time
i felt that depressed reading something
was always an improvement it also
okay i've never i've not read oh yeah
yeah i also this is the oyster
point